体と心の 注意すべきポイント
3つの条件 これから今日のテーマなんです
マジュヒムニカイ 7番目ね
聞いてあげる するとこんな文章があります
これはあのある文章から
真ん中一部だけ切っちゃったんで
だから文章は完成していないんです
ここまで書いたってのはね
面倒くさいね 読むのはね
次に行きます だからこの文章を切っちゃったんだから
この方々は  1 適切な儒教があって
に善友と付き合う機会があって
３ 五感を管理することによって
両家の人は出家する その目的に間もないうちに現実に達して経験して住むのではないかという意味を持って
不放逸になりなさいと説くのですと
これ ブッダが言うんですね
私は この方々は上級の方々で
解脱に達したい 苦しみをなくしたいという目的で出家していて
ですから私はこの方々は適切な儒教があって
適切な善友にすっと付き合って
五感を管理して 早くも現実に今ここで最終解脱に達してほしいんだよと
だから不放逸に頑張ってくださいといいますよという引用文がありまして
これは繰り返し繰り返しこの経典であります
この順番がちょっと私は間違っているような気がするので
日本訳ではね ちょっと原文を見ます
はいはい 同じ順番です
私は説明すると順番変えます
変えましたのでね はい
それから適切な儒教ということにいきます
これはあの日常生活がね
必要な飲食 呪薬という 4つが入ります
適切な儒教という項目に体の状況が悪くなると
必ず心はダメになるんです
この体が悪くなっちゃうと
必ず心が悪くなっちゃうんです
例えば誰かがね 針でここら辺どこか刺しちゃうとね
気持ち悪くなるでしょ
痛い痛いし 何するのかと
そこで皆さんは今 いきなり体が調子が悪くて
痛くて もう病気になっちゃうと
もう勉強する気持ちがなくなっちゃうでしょ
だから心は体に期待しているんです
我々の心が体に期待していますよ
私を守ってくれと 体が心が独裁者だからね
体に命令するのはもうしょうがないんです
君に期待しているんだからね
と我々の体に心が言ってるんです
だから体に責任がありますよ
そういうわけで 仏教苦行は禁止
なんで苦行して体をいじめるといじめられるの
誰ですかね 心でしょ いじめられて成功はしませんだからね
いじめられたら壊れるだけ
だから仏教は切れちゃったり
苦行は禁止 俗世間でも闇雲に苦労しても良い結果が出ないでしょう
だから徹夜しただけで走っただけで
荷物を持ってただ単にそんなだけでご苦労さん
もうちょっとありますよ
体にも親切でないとね
心は成長しない はい それから肉体の調整
苦行を避けて贅沢をすると
明らかに体依存主義なんですね
はい ブッダが苦行はダメと言ったんだから
これから俺は贅沢三昧でやっちゃうぞと言っちゃうと
その人は肉体至上主義
依存過ぎなんです 心は馬鹿にしているんです
だからそれもダメなんです
贅沢もダメ 苦行もダメ
麻薬で幸福を感じることと同じですよ
贅沢にふけることは だから我々は体のことを心配するならば
苦行は絶対やめる 断食やら滝行やら
もうアホなことは全部やめる
山を登ってもいいんだけど
健康のためであるならば
山が美しいであるならば
友達に自慢したいと思うならば
どうぞ登ってください
足腰も強いならば だからで遭難したり死んだり
あんなアホなことはやめてほしい
嵐が来るそうだったら
行く山はやめた方がよろしい
登っちゃいけないというわけじゃなくて
登ったんだからといって何のこともないんです
だからそこをちゃんと中道考えてほしい
登ることによって楽しいんだとかね
まあ体鍛えできるんだとかね
写真見せ見せて 友達の間でね
空自慢できるぞとかね
まあそういう何とか結果があれば登るのは構いませんしね
体も心もそうすると堕落しますね
贅沢に陥ると堕落します
体の管理に対して中道を守る
ちゃんと体のことで中道を守るんです
激しい空腹 寒さ 暑さを避けるんです
これ大体この出家にしているアドバイスから
私はこの変化して使っているんです
修行する人々は激しい空腹をダメなんです
激しい寒さも激しい暑さも避けなくちゃいけない
零度以下のところで もう足を組んで座ると
もう馬鹿以外何でもないんです
道元禅師のテキストの中であるエピソードがあって思い出しましたけど
道元さんが自分の弟子たちにね
あれやこれやともう贅沢言うなよと
道元禅師はかなり拙速で苦しく
もうお坊さんらしく生活していたんだからね
あの 中国ではね 座禅組んでる禅師たちはね
まあまあまあまあ これ眉毛もこうか
こういうところ 眉毛とか真っ白くなるんだと
なぜかというと 自分の住んでいるところで
屋根がね あまり綺麗に拭いてなくて
雪が落ちて落ちて 体中も白くなっている
それでもじっと朝まで座禅組んでいるんだと
だからあんた方はね よく覚えてください
ということは 文句言わないということなんだけど
私から見ればね だから馬鹿以外何でもないでしょうと
だって悟ったっていうことはないんだからね
頑張り 座禅組んだことだけはちゃんと記録してますけど
それから蚊 虫 蛇 炎症を起こす感触を避けなくちゃいけない
私は修行していたからね
蚊に刺されたっても まあいっちゃらとかね
気にしませんとか 幸福でありますようにと
マレリアにかかるかもしれませんよ
だからってブッダは蚊を殺せと言っているわけじゃないんです
あのタイの信者さん 見てください
あのインドに行って 菩提樹のところでみんなもう瞑想するんですね
場所を取って 強引に で
みんな蚊帳を持って行ってくれ
ちゃんとぶら下がって
その中に入って しっかり仏教的にやっているんです
ブッダが悟ったところで 1
時間でも1日だけでも修行したいんだと
その味わいたいんだと
そのブッダが使った場所
しかし蚊が困るとイライラするんだと
瞑想をするどころじゃなくて
腹が立って腹が立って
もう殺したい気持ちになるんでしょうね
だから蚊帳を使うんです
それが仏教の中道なんです
それで木に背を背もたれてね
瞑想する 構いませんだけど
そちらでいろんなものあって
もう背中が炎症を起こしちゃうとどうする？そこは避けてくださいと
昼夜睡眠をとる でなきゃ瞑想できないんですよ
昼夜ですね だから面白いでしょう
あの脳の必要ななんだらかんだらとか
いろいろありますね なんて言いますか
あれは あのホルモンでしたっけ？成長ホルモンやらいろんなもの
あれは夜出すんですよ
だから修行者は昼夜寝るんです
昼夜っていうのは  10時からまあ 2時あたり
だから体のこと決して無視してないんです
しかし 怠けに注意する
あ お釈迦様は空腹感は良くないと言ったんだから
いつでもおせんべい食べながらダメです
いつでも 30 分ごとにお茶飲みながら
あ 寝てくださいと言ったんだから
俺が寝るぞとか  8時間以上とか
それはダメです  10時から 2時までとかね
ある程度の暑さ 寒気 空腹などを忍耐するんです
ある程度の 例えば 24
24度まで暖房ガンガンかけてね
瞑想どころじゃなくて
ぐーぐー寝ちゃうでしょうね
だから部屋の中に瞑想する場合は
暖房を切った方がいいんじゃないんですかね
ちこっと寒いんだけど
もう我慢できる程度で
そういうことも考えてください
ある程度の空腹ね まあちょこちょこっと空腹なんですけど
そうすると体がすごく機能するんです
はい 心は活発であるならば
その時は睡眠時間であっても仕事をしている
瞑想するとどんどん心が活発になっちゃって機能し出すんですね
その場合だけ 今は睡眠時間なんですけど
続けて仕事をするんです
なぜならば 効率脳率が上がっているんです
だったら一日中寝ていてもどうったこともないんです
結果が出ますからね そういう風に中道
体を洗って清潔にしたり
時々サウナを利用して血液の流れを調整したりするんです
これ びっくりでしょ？出家にはサウナに入れと言ってるんです
当時のインドで インド人は今もね
あまりお風呂に入れません
見たことはないです まああんた長い時間いたこともないでしょと言うのかもしれませんだけど
ね なんか汚いんですけど
だからこそ 仏教はあえて体洗いなさいよと言いつつも
気をつけろよと なぜかというと
体を洗いなさいと言ったら
ある一部の坊さんたちが
まあ今お風呂に入る時間だとか
お風呂ではなくて あの沐浴の時間だと言って
さーっと行って 川に入って体を洗って洗って
もう衣を綺麗に洗って出てきて
あー疲れました で まあ次のこと
それで修行する時間どうするのかと
今瞑想したら あ まあでも瞑想ですけど
まあこれはやりますからね
今 3時ですから お風呂に行きますとかね
いい加減にしろよとブッダが言うんです
だったら そういうおしゃれで肉体の目的で美しく見せるために
毎日毎日体洗うなよと
しかし 週 2回ぐらいでもやらなきゃまたダメやと
それについても見事な中道なんです
えーと 体が病気になった場合
超能力を使う 手当で治らない時は医者のお世話になるんです
超能力は使いません ハンドパワー使いませんで
で 私にもなんとかなんとこうやってあげますとかね
私は断ります 嫌です いや
あんたもうこれ証拠はありません
それでも嫌です 薬で飲みたい
薬飲みたいんです で 気持ち的に落ち込んで調子が悪くなると
あの病気も あの ただ体が病気になる場合もあるし
気持ちがあまり優れてない場合も病気がちになっちゃいますよ
うつ的になっちゃうんですね
うつがかかっちゃうと体が壊れるんですよ
それでガンガン薬飲んじゃうととんでもないんです
だから病気になったら必ず薬ではなくて
医学的な病気の場合は薬に頼ると
うつ的になって気持ちがなんか作れない状態で病気になると
別な治療法があります
はい その時は超能力を使う
ですかね お経を読んだり
対話をしたり 仏教ってなんせとかね
苦笑帯ってなんせとかね
仏教を学んだり 精進する仲間の中に入ったりするんです
いわゆる臼を破るんです
あー瞑想する気持ちもないし
イライラするし 退屈で
まあいやいや これだったらお経でも勉強しようかと
言って ぐちゃぐちゃ勉強している
あるいは勉強したものは全部解説してみたりする
あるいは頭のいい先生のところに行って質問したり
議論したりすると もう心が復活してきます
残念ですね 超能力使うところなかなか出てこない
あるのに 持病がないのに体力つける薬は禁止
精力剤とかなんとか Ｄ
とがなんとかＥＸとか
なんで日本人がＥＸは好きですかね
なんとかリコプ なんとかなんとかＤとかね
なんとかＢＢとかね なんだあれはね
馬鹿にされてますよ で
食事においてね 決して満腹になるまで食べない
仏教は よく噛んで味わってゆっくり食べるんです
それも本当は決まりなんです
食べるものは噛んで その味を味わって食べるんだけど
この美味しく食べるっていうことじゃないんで
これが美味しいんだから食っちゃうぞではなくて
口に入れたもん入れたものの味を味わうんです
この味の感覚 味覚も栄養なんです
味覚も触覚も肉体に栄養になるんです
単なる感覚なんですけど
食べ物は早く飲み込むのではなく
はい 食った食ったではないんです
口に入ったものを全部噛み砕いて飲み込むのは理想的なんです
できれば抜群効果が出ますよ
口に入れたものは全部噛み砕くと
なかなか誰も実行しないんだけどね
お腹に入ったものの もう大体4分の1も噛んでないんです
だからお腹にとってはもうお荷物でも溶けないでしょ
液体に 本当は大量に食べる必要はないんで
食べる口に入れたものは噛んで噛んで噛んで噛んで噛んで
ほとんど液体にして飲み込むんです
ものの見事に体が栄養を取るんです
それであの食べ物の無駄遣いがなくなっちゃうんです
出家は体を維持でき 維持できる量
食べる量は出家には体を維持できる量っていうのはね
現代は 1 日何カロリーでしたっけ？ 1 日の摂取するカロリー量は3000
そのぐらいですね  で 3000
カロリー あっですね 出家は
で ただ死なない程度 まあこれぐらいだったら死なないでしょう
病気にならないでしょうという程度なんです
まあ在家の場合はね まあ 1 日使用する体力に合わせて合わせた摂取ですね
在家にも食いまくれと言ってないんです
1 日今日はこういうこういう仕事あるんだって
朝食べちゃうと あるいは今日はクタクタ仕事をしました
では夜いくら食べますよというふうに
体力に合わせ使う体力に合わせてくださいというのが仏教の教えなんです
それから栄養バランス
在家にできるが 托鉢生活する出家には現実的にできない
実現できないんですね
仏教は栄養バランスも大事なポイントとして見ています
戒律本ではたくさん書いています
栄養バランスも大事です
例えば何か栄養が欠けちゃうと脳が動かなくなっちゃうんですね
ビタミン欠けていくと
ビタミン欠けちゃうとすごい大変なことになります
だからもうそれも必要なんで
だから出家どうしますかね
托鉢しに行くんだから
しかし 栄養失調で悩んでいた出家に適切なアドバイスをした例が律宗にあります
お釈迦さん言ったら あんたね
魚介類を食べた方がいいんだよとは言えないでしょ
面白いことお釈迦様は結構知ってるんです
この医学のことかなり詳しい
ある比丘がね すごいこの貧血病でいつでもうとうとしていて
頑張るんだけど頑張れないんですね
もう色も褪せちゃって白くなっちゃって
その聞いたね あんたすごい調子が悪いんだけど
で 見ただけで分かったんで
病気は あんたどこに住んでるの？と聞いたんだ
なんたかなんとか村やと
ああ そう 君はね 命令する
これからなんとかなんとか村で生活しなさい
はいはい それだけ それでそのお釈迦様の命令だから
はい わかりましたと言って
自分住んでるお寺から自分の衣を持って
ずっと別なお釈迦様が認定した村に行ったんです
いて そこでちょこっと家を作り作って生活を始めたんです
托鉢といったら みんな漁師たち
漁師ではなくて まあ魚を取ったり
托鉢に魚の料理が入るんです
それで 1週間で元気になっちゃって悟ります
いただく食べ物は体に合わない場合は
密かにその村を離れて別なところに住むんです
これしか出家にはできないんです
親兄弟以外はこれ言ってはならんですよ
だからそこ在家にはそんなに大きな問題じゃない
しかし リミットがあります
肉体の面倒を見るのは肉体のためではありません
肉体は捨てるものです
解脱するまで 心は体を媒体にして機能するから
媒体として道具として管理するだけです
だから皆さん覚えてください
体を気をつけてください
しかし 体はあくまでも道具です
肉体主義はダメです 大工が道具を大事にする程度です
大工が自分の道具はすごい大事にするでしょ
触らせてくれませんね
あれ 道具信仰しているじゃないんです
仕事に使うんです 自分がむちゃくちゃ使ってるんです
が ちょっとこれちょっと貸してくれ
え ダメって言うんです
触るなよと 大事な商売道具だからと怒られるでしょ
だから我々も肉体は道具なんです
そんな程度で考えてほしいんです 2
番目 この感覚の調整にしたんです
眼耳鼻舌身に触れる情報によって
もう時間ですかね  5時半までですけど
少しちょっと休んだ方がいいんですね
ちょっと休みましょう
はい あの だから 1番目は体の調整 2
番目はこの五感の調整ということに入ります
で 五感に勉強してみましょう
眼耳鼻舌身というね 五感がありますね
それに触れる情報によって
心は激しく揺れるのです
これはわかりますね 目に入るもの
耳に入ることによって
我々の心がすごく揺れるんですね
これはどうしようもないのです
で 欲 怒り 嫉妬などの煩悩が起こるのです
自分は何も悪いことをしていないのに
見えたものによって怒りが生まれるでしょう
例えば映画なんか見てみるとそうでしょう
怒りが出るわ 欲が出るわ
いろいろ ただ座ってるだけなんですけど
目に目から入る情報で
それから耳から入る情報も同じでしょ
耳に音しか入らないんだけど
それによって怒るは欲張るは混乱するは落ち込むはとか
心の中 激しく揺れ動くんです
人は五感からの刺激に依存するんですね
それで それの悪いことは
我々は五感に頼らなくちゃダメでしょうね
目に頼らなきゃ生きていられないし
耳に頼らなきゃ生きていられないしね
舌の感覚が死んじゃったら大変でしょうに
だから五感が必要でしょうに
だから当然我々は五感に頼っている
しかし これがまた問題で
心が激しい竜巻を起こしちゃうんですね
そこでものを見るが 心に欲と怒りが起こらないようにするんです
そこで目を開けてちゃんと生きてますよ
しかし 欲と怒りが起こらないようにする
例えば 美しい花を咲いている子を見たら
ああ 結構綺麗 なんて綺麗ですかね
ああ 好き それダメです
なんて綺麗 私は日本で生まれてよかったとかね
やっぱり日本って世界一美しい国だとかね
アホなことをしないでください
心が汚れて破壊する 結構美しいですね
結構デザイン的に考えて花を置いてるんだとかね
これはどういう花？ああ
ああいう花 あ これは南米の
あ なるほど 南米の花 あ
結構日本でもうまく咲いてますねとかね
そういう風に喜びば十分でしょ
ちょっと理性的で 耳 鼻なども同じように
あ これはなかなかいい香りだ
なんか癒し系の香りだなとか
それで終えて終えてください
なんていい香りですか
これどうどうどうどんなもの？どこで売ってる？これがダメなんです
で 何か香りが あ これ結構落ち着く香りだなとかね
自分の部屋に一つ置いといたって悪くないんですけど
どこで手に入る？はい
なんとか店で はい この
この このうち買ってみますとかね
そういう風にこの必要なことはするんだけど
激しい感情に陥らないようにします
これ 欲の場合 怒りの場合も同じなんですね
なんてことですか ではなくて
あ これはちょっとね やめた方がいいと思いますけどとかね
そういう当時ね ちょっと調子に冷静にするんです
それで激しい感情がなくなるんです
で 猛獣を興奮させないとやり方なんです
これで覚えられますよ
猛獣をいじるんじゃないんです
興奮させないんです これが五感の制御なんです
ここまでは体の調整とも言えるんです
今までの説明は体の調整なんで
五感の調整の体なんです
心は猛獣のような恐ろしいものです
食べ物が口に合わなかっただけでも
何をするかわからない人なんです
いますよ ちょっと食べ物口に合わなかっただけで
とんでもないことをする
現実的な例がないんだから
ジャータカ物語を紹介します
あるジャータカ物語がありまして
このある王様がいるんですね
この人が毎日毎日肉を食べているんですね
一日も肉なしは食うなしなんです
もうしかし 当時インドでは毎日動物を殺してはならないということにしているんです
動物の資源がなくなりますからね
だから殺生してはいけない日は決めちゃうんですね
それはまあ小僧界で まあ満月ですから
当時の暦ではね 月ですね
だから満月 新月 半月で回で
そこでこの王がこの満月なんですね
料理は作ったんですけど
台所のコックさんたちが肉が手に入らなかったんです
ちょっと前もって買っておくこと
ちょっと忘れちゃったんです
満月はもう国民が食べません
だから王様のことだから
もう前の日で 2日分は買っておかなくちゃいけない
で 冷蔵庫がないでしょ
だから毎日買わなくちゃいけないんですよ
ですから そこはコックさんが何か工夫するでしょう
王様がいっぱい酒飲んで
自分の赤ちゃんがいたんですね
赤ちゃんは好きで好きで
酒飲んでたって赤ちゃんを抱っこして
いろいろかわいかわやいないいないばあとしながら
じゃあ食事の時間になってる
で見たら何もないんですね
肉は 激怒しない これは何や
これはこれは及第点ですかと
そしたらみんなもうこれは申し訳ない
もう満月だから肉は手に入らなかった
なんで肉がないのかと言って
これ作ってくれ 自分の赤ちゃん の首を入れちゃった
それ作ってこいと 肉いくらでもあるでしょうにと頭怒られちゃったんですね
あの子供がなんか動物に見えたでしょうね
で 王の命令だからね で
料理作ってくれたんです
なかなかこれ料理かいなとかね
で 食っちゃったんです
食ってもうそれからまあ酔いも覚めて
また子供と遊ばなくちゃとか
赤ちゃん連れてこいと命令するんです
誰も応じませんね お妃が泣きながら王様のとこで
あんた なんで今更赤ちゃんを見せてくれた？あなた食べたでしょ
えっ？何これって 俺が自分の息子を食べるってことあるのかと
命より私は可愛がっていたではないかと
ああそうと あなたは酒飲んで酔っ払って肉ばっかし食いたくてね
やったんでしょうと  それで目が覚めたと
もう遅いんですけどね
だからそのジャータカ物語でも言ってるのはね
いかに心が猛獣かっていうことなんです
だからストーリーだからもうこの上ないというふうに残酷に作ってます
で 我々ももう別に守られてるわけじゃないんですよ
ちょっとしたことで猛獣になりますよ
ちょっと一言間違っただけで
付き合ってる相手を殺したりとかするでしょうに
だから気をつけてください
我々の心っていうのは恐ろしい猛獣だから
そーっとしてあげてください
刺激を怒りてよくだけが生まれないように気をつけるんです
これは五感の調整なんです
体の調整も感覚の調整も
心という猛獣が興奮しないで落ち着いていられるようにする工夫なんです
はい 最後に行きます 戦友との付き合い
それから心の制御と成長の課題です
なんかタイトルと中身合わないね
戦友との付き合いと なんだここれは
と合いますよ 溶岩のようにわがままな心は
触れる程度の温度に1と2の処理方法で下がるんです
人の心ってのは溶岩みたいなもんですよ
また 独裁者に主人で親分で
他人にはどうすることもできないんです
そこで体の調整で 食べ物の調整で
住むところの調整で 病気になったらいろいろ調整して
肉体を調整する 体を体を調整すると心が落ち着いてくる
次に五感を調整する そうするとさらに心が落ち着いてくる
溶岩であった心が今触っても大丈夫
まだまだ暖かいんだけど
熱いんだけど まあ触らない
触れないわけじゃないんです
心は本来無知なので 真理を発見できるように集中力と観察力をつけてあげあげなくてはならないんです
はい これから心にちょっと宿題出すんです
もうもうもう溶岩が温かい程度になってるんです
熱い程度に それから集中力と観察力を育てなさいと自分の心に言うんです
というより自分でやるんです
このやり方を教える専修とはブッダなのです
だから専有と心の制御なんです
これが発見したのはブッダ
心を育てる方法 で それ教えられるのはブッダ以外は誰もない
この心だけは誰にも発見できない難しいややこしいものなんです
これは整理整頓して明確に科学的に発見して解かれてあります
ですから ブッダが心を成長させる方法も知っています
それは集中力と観察  2つです
それで心は成長します
ですから 専修と付き合いなさいというのは
心を成長しなさいという意味なんです
で 専修っていうのはブッダが自分だと
我々全然ならないんです
お釈迦様もとっても先に
どうしようもない 私も専修になりたいんだけどね
お釈迦様 専修とは私のことやと言ってますから
もう恐れ多くて 悪友にはなれますけどね
だから皆様の私にも善行はお釈迦様なんです
はい 次 心にはなくすものがあるんです
基本的な非道徳である怒り
嫉妬 傲慢 自我 欲などを戒律
道徳という形で制御するのです
はい それからブッダの世界
で まず道徳を守らなくちゃいけないんです
道徳ではまた怒り 欲 嫉妬
傲慢などなどを管理するんです
しかし 中道に注意 戒律は儀式でも行でもカルトでもないんです
これだけ覚えてください
仏教はよくテレビで言いますよ
仏教 浄土仏教はものすごい戒律中心にする
する 戒律にも閉じ込め込まれているものあれやこれやと
戒律厳しいとかなんて何知ってるんですかね
日本の仏教は仏教でないだけの話でしょうに
形だけで仏像だけでしょ
テレビの仏教番組で言ったっても
仏像巡りで終わっちゃいますからね
で 何のこともないんです
だからこの上座仏教はテーラワーダ仏教は戒律主義じゃないんです
で カルトでもないんです
行でもないんです 己の心の汚れを制御する目的で行うものです
だから戒律項目はそれほど大事じゃないんです
それによって心が汚れないようにするだけ
です もし何か食べ物がある
これ食べちゃうと自分があまりも好物だからね
もう量が破ってぐちゃぐちゃ食ってしまう可能性もあります
お腹が壊すところまで食ってしまう可能性もあります
だったら これ煩悩でしょ
そこで戒律する 両方知って空想
信者さんがね あなたの好物だからもう持ってきましたから
いっぱい食べてくださいと言っても
自分がほんの一部いただいて
他はさっさと他のお坊さんにあげてくださいと分けるんです
自分だけに持ってきたのに
そこで戒律が割り込む
なぜならば 自分の煩悩が刺激を受けるんだから
それでまあ全部それだけ食べたってよ
別に心を落ち着けるというのは
別に戒律は関係ないんです
せっかく持ってきたんだから
まあしょうがない いただきますと
その人は体が維持する程度で食べますよ
これ食べてるんだから
だから形にとらわれたらダメなんです
形だけの戒律にしがみつくのも煩悩だというんです
この戒禁取って皆様聞いたことあるでしょ
シーラッパタパラマーサットというね
戒禁取っていう煩悩なんですね
ですから戒律はいいんだけど
戒禁取になってはならないんです
いるでしょ の中で 私はなんでしたっけ？えーと
えーと えーと えーと 菜食主義者だとかね
私はなんだらかんだら主義者だとかね
私は 1 日朝しか食べない主義だよと
勝手にしろよと そんな形はどうでもいいんです
心はきれいになるのはあなたの主義で
そういうことで 仏教はたくさん戒律ありますけど
いつでも目的があっての戒律なんです
育つもの それはたくさんあります
省略すると 信頼 精進 気づき
譲渡へなんですね 説明する時間はございません
サッダービジェサリサマディパンニャーという五力五根です
五力ともいうし 五根ともいうんですね
根っこは 5つです その根っこをしっかりつけると
解脱という木が成長するんです
また八正道もあります
その場合は 8項目ですね
七覚支ともありますね
その場合は 7項目ですね
いろんな方法で教えてありますよ
37にしている場合もあるし
ブッダの観察瞑想で順番で自然に成長
成長していくものです
だからあまり心配しないでください
37を育てる やりすぎ
やりすぎとかね やっていられないとかね
気にすることはないんです
ただ お釈迦様の観察瞑想を始めれば
じわじわと全部起きて
起きて 起きて成長していくのです
完璧な方法なんです この場合は個人差が見えます
お釈迦様の瞑想に入った途端
ただ観察するだけ いわゆる気づき瞑想
ヴィパッサナー瞑想 それをやるだけ
何のことも面白くもないね
実況中継するだけだから
精進しているという気分もしないし
頑張っているという気分もしないし
しかし 結構大変ですけどね
妄想しないということはね
で そこで個人差が出てくるんです
簡単に現れる善もあるし
なかなか起こりにくい善も人によってあります
ここで瞑想している 妄想ばっかりしている人のことをこれから言いません
もうある程度で瞑想はできる人々
妄想がなかなかそんなにも出てこない人々の場合は見えるんですよ
あ この人はこの子の善が簡単にできているんだと
しかし この善はなかなか
ある人は知ってますよ
必要な善はほとんど揃ってます
1個だけ揃わないんです
だからもう何年もやってますけど
瞑想は終了しないんです
私は言うは言うは いや
これに欠けてますよと
本人もこれはよく知ってますけどと
私はこれ欠けてるんだと
だからどうしますかね
本人も知っている 私も言っている
だからブッダがいないんだからしょうがないんだけども
お互い試行錯誤で まあいろいろなんとか何とか考えてはいるんですね
見事に他は全部揃ってます
ただ 1個だけ そういう個人差が出てくるんです
仏教を学ぶと 自分でサッダーを育てましょう
ヴィリヤを育てましょうというように
個人プログラムを組む場合もあります
いるんですよ 嫌な連中は
仏教を学んで だって自由な世界でしょ
仏教は 私はこれで頑張る
私はこれで頑張るとかね
勝手に決めるんですね
そこで私たちに報告してもやめなさいという権利はないんです
だっていいことに頑張ってるんだからね
私はとにかくサッダ あのサッダって何だろう
確信 納得する 理解する
私は理解することに最初に頑張るぞと
ああ 結構ですよ 仏教は理解してやるぞと
納得するまで勉強するぞと
ダメと言える？誰かさんがね
私が納得するまで勉強するつもりですと
本を紹介してくださいと言うと
どうします？私は だったらこれ
この本を読んでくださいと言うしかないでしょうに
しかし もしかすると私にはね
この人にはその性格的には合わないんじゃないかなとかね
無理じゃないかなとかね
感じますよ でもどうしようもないんです
あるいは何もわかってない
もう他の信仰型の宗教ばっかりやってきて
仏教に来て 私はこれこれいろんな宗教をやってみたんだから
これからそんなこと捨てちゃって
ブッダの瞑想をやりたいと
ちょっとまだ早いんじゃないなと気分がするんですよ
これがもう一つカルトにするだろう
この人はと わかるんだけど
瞑想したい やめなさいと言える？言えないんです
ブッダ ブッダも時々その落とし穴に落ちるんです
あのナーギタという もうこのナギさんではないんだけど
もうお坊さんがいて お釈迦様の親戚なんですよ
で 釈迦族でしょ？王家でしょ
お釈迦様とどこかで昼ご飯を食べて
お釈迦様は鉢を持って
二人で親戚だからね まあゆっくり仲良く歩いているんですね
そういうとってもきれいな公園見たんです
美しくて 動物 鳥たちがさえずったりとかね
で なんてきれいな公園ですかとか
ナギさん言うんですね
結構穏やかな気分になりますと
やっぱり瞑想するのならば
こんな場所はすごくいいんですね
で お釈迦様 私はこのまま瞑想
修行に入ります どうぞ鉢を持ってくださいと言ったら
お釈迦様がナーギタ 今私は全く一人でいるんだよと
で これも偉い方だから
お釈迦様はね だから一人で置いてはいけないんですね
誰か失礼なことでもしたら地獄に落ちるでしょ
その人は あるいはお釈迦様
お釈迦様 自分の姿を見せなくちゃいけないでしょ
自分があると だから何人か周りにいると
これお釈迦様だよと言ったら
みんなもうお世話おいて感じになりますからね
私は今一人ですから お寺に戻るまで待てない
お釈迦様は何をおっしゃるんですかね
私は今 その気分になったんだと
瞑想する気分だ だから修行に入ると
お釈迦様 またやめなさいと言うんです
それでは 3回目も言うんです
言っただけではなく お釈迦様
鉢をお手になればこちらに置いておきますと下に置いておいたんですよ
誰もやらないことなんですよ
親戚だから  義理の兄弟にもなりますからね
あんた持たない じゃあ置いとく
まあ兄弟喧嘩ですからね
お釈迦様もしょうがなく
鉢を持って寺に帰った
この人はジャングル 森に入って瞑想を始めたんです
始めたら サイケで女の人々と遊んだことばっかり思い浮かんだんですね
まあ頭を横切るわ 横切るわ
横切るわ 本人もびっくりしちゃったんです
なんだこれやと 私は全部捨てて出家したんじゃないかと
こんな詐欺インチキやるつもりないでしょうにと
なんでこの心は もうとんでもないことになってびっくりして怖くなっちゃって
瞑想さっさとやめて お釈迦様のところに行ってもうぶかぶかと謝ったんです
申し訳なかった 申し訳なかったと
お釈迦様も叱ったんですね
ブッダがやめろと言ったらやめなさいよと
だから落とし穴 ブッダさんも落ちるんです
もうしょうがないんです
これ 勉強する 勉強する人々に出てくる我我なんですね
しかし それも必ずしも外れているわけでもないんです
必ずしも外れてるわけでもない
例えば私に読めないんだけど
その人のその能力はある可能性もある
だから本人が決まったプログラムでいったっても構わないとかもありますよし
結構難しいんです しかし
全ての善が均等にならなくてはいけないんです
だから心の場合は 善と良いところは全部均等にならないと悟りに達しないんですね
それでお釈迦様がおっしゃったように
気づきの瞑想を始めたらすぐバレます
性格のいろんな波が バレますっていうのは失礼な言葉ですけど
明確に見えてきます そうすると
アドバイスの調整で調整で育てるようにしてあげることはできます
自分でプログラム組んだらもう知ったことではない
こちらには横から何も言う権利はなく
できなくなっちゃうんです
で 最初からもう稀ですが
善が均等になりやすい人もいます
時々いますよ 最初から人格は整っていて
智慧もあるし 頑張るし
もう物事を判断もできる人とかね
丸くなった人々 そういう人々は修行に入っちゃうと高速で悟りに達します
大体人間というのはそんなに均等じゃないんですよ
人格というのはいつでもバラバラで傾いてもね
どうかに だからその傾いたものをまっすぐにして育てる場合
ちょっと時間かかります
普通はバラバラに善が成長するんです
人間の善というのはバラバラに成長する
ある 1週間ぐらい一生懸命頑張っちゃいますけど
次の週になっちゃうと
もう頑張るつもりがなくて
もう勉強したくてたまらなくなっちゃうんですね
だから頑張る場合は集中力が育ちますけど
勉強をしたくなっちゃう
集中力は 1 影もなくなっちゃう
その代わりに理解が成長したりはする
だからそれバラバラなんですね
ある程度で善が身についたら均等に保つんです
そこでバラバラでいいんです
バラバラでも 例えばABCDからGまであるとしましょう A
がいくらか 30点まで上がったと
次  D ももう 20点まで上がったと
まあ F もまあもう 35点まで上がったとかね
それで適当に上がったところで均等にするんですね
全部線を 誰でも気づきの実践から修行を始めるんです
だから誰でも気づきという善を始まるんです
気づきが始まると 次 観察能力が出てくるんです
理性が現れてくるんです
それから精進する気持ちが出てくるんです
あと 順番で善が出てきて引いてくれます
均等といっても中道 この均等
均等と言ったのは中道という言葉なんです
だから心も中道 体も中道なんです
アビダンマアビダンマではタッラマッジャッタタという心象がありますね
ウペッカーという心象がありますね
その心象 2つでこの均等というものは考えているんです
七覚支ではウペッカーサンボッジャンガという項目があります
ウペッカーというのはシャーと書きます
それも均等にするという意味なんですね
八正道は最初の教えですね
ブッダの悟りに達する教えの最初は八正道なんですね
これは教えで正道という言葉
あ 王道なんですね 八正道は本当は王道ですけどね
そちらではありよう サンマーという形容詞で均等であるべきことを示します
八正道の場合 例えばサンマーディッティとありますね
正見 それはありよう サンマーディッティですね
ありよう 聖なるサンマーというのは正見ディッティですね
だからありようとサンマーで
これはバランスを整えて育てなさいと
偏見はダメと偏ってはダメということなんです
心の因縁なので 縁 因と縁が揃ったところで自ら解脱に達するんです
ただ 我々の仕事はこの線を全部全部揃う
コレクターみたいに全部いいものは全部セット揃ったらそれから OK という
はい これで結論 体の調整も中道です
バランスが不可欠です
体を無視することと心の成長もない
だから決して体を無視して体を馬鹿にして瞑想だけにするということは
これはありえないんです
心の成長に入ると 悪をなくすことも
善に達することもバランスよく中道です
ただ単に悪をなくそうと頑張っちゃうと
やけに悪が生まれることがあります
例えば 俺は食欲には弱い
だから断食するそうと
それで食欲なくなくなると思う
逆です 恐ろしく食欲が増えてくるんです
俺があんまりこの怠けで
まあ食欲寝ちゃうし そんな頑張らないし
今度こそ徹夜してやっちゃうぞと思っちゃうと怠けが消えると思う
逆効果なんです  1 日はやっちゃいますけど
それから 1ヶ月寝ちゃう
だからいつでもバランス
バランス バランスなんです
だからはっきり言いますよ
私たち言うこと聞きなさいと
正直素直に なんか私たちはなんかからかっていい加減に言っているように聞こえるでしょう
でも本当は結構気をつけて言ってるんです
人にストレスかけてあげたくないんです
余計な緊張感はあげちゃうとバランス崩れますよ
だからあんたね まあもうちょっとやれよ
そんなもんだよと そんな感じで言ってますよ
これはダメとは言いませんね
だからこちらはもういかに均等になるように
バランスを取れるようにということにも大変苦労していますけど
だからもう問題はその道行かないだけですからね
で 善のみに達する時も
精神者は均等に最強力でなくてはならないんです
そこで悪がじわじわと落ちていく
で 善だけ残る 善だけ残ったら
それは最高なレベルに上げる
最強力 全部均等に上げたら
次のステップは自動的に飛びます
解脱 心ははい だから心の成長は別枠になるんです
これは仏教だけの話で
しかし 仏教では体が体と心がもう不可分離で一緒に機能するんです
私の心を変えたければ
皆様にはとっても簡単ですよ
ちょっとこうやって去っただけでも十分です
私はこうやっていくと
誰かが後ろからそうさったら
指であれ何？と言うでしょう
心が変わったんです それぐらい簡単ですよ
体と心の関係は だから体のことも気をつけて
体は真似 言ったような通りで
ちゃんと整えてあげて
食べ物は腹八分目という日本語の言葉ですけど
で まあそんな感じで それから腹八分目でなくてもいいんです
口に入れたものは全部溶けるまで食べてみる
噛んでみる それから美味しいものを追っていくんじゃなくて
口に入ったものの味を感じてみる
そういうことで見事な健康な体になります
それから本当に病気になる場合もあります
その場合は まあお釈迦様はまあ普通に対応しません
ある日 お坊さんたちがなんか住んでるところの食べ物がまずくて
まあインドっていうのはものすごい大きい国でしょ
民族もそれぞれ違うし
だから食べるものも食べられるものはそれぞれの文化にありますし
このお坊さんたちがいる場所で食べ物は食べたくはない
だからといって托鉢だからしょうがない
そこでお坊さん食べるんだけど
みんな吐いちゃうんです
気持ち悪くて  自動的にもう上がっちゃうんですね
そこで次の日のまあ どれほど精神的に苦しんだでしょうね
次の日も托鉢したらまた同じものもらったり
まだ食べますけど お腹が空いてるんだから
だって苦労して食べるんですよ
まあ上がっちゃいますけど
食べ食べて終わってもやっぱり出しちゃいます
それでお釈迦様はなんかで報告されましたけど
お釈迦様見たらみんなもう倒れたまんまで
おお ああ やれやれ これはと
お釈迦様 それでこの際は一人でお考えになったんです
どうすればよろしいかと
それで思い浮かんだんですね
あ  7つのものがあるんだと
私はこれはみんなに認定してあげればいいんじゃないかないかと
あれ  7つだったっけ？うん
それは体にいいんだと
もう栄養はありすぎですけど
1つはバター もう一つはギギっていうのは
この牛乳から脂分だけ取っちゃうんですね
あれもうコレステロールそのものなんです
あの牛乳から出ます 作りますけどもね
我々現代的に見ればコレステロールのものですけど
インドではものすごい贅沢な食べ物なんですね
それからあのヤシとかね
取るとる黒砂糖 それからはちみつ
もう一つなんかあったっけ
忘れた 私はあの 7つも大嫌いだからね
サッピナワニートマドゥパニと
もう記憶がない サッピーとナワニート
マドゥパニかって 向かってるのよ
え？で まあとにかくこの牛乳から取るものとハチミツと黒砂糖ですね
それは使ったらいいんじゃないかと
すごい私はびっくりしますよ
だから何も食べてない人々が
食べられない人々が 例えばバターとね
ハチミツを混ぜて食べたら
もうほんのわずかの量でしょ
これでも 2 3日間でも大丈夫ですよ
体は だから いかにお釈迦様が物事をちゃんと考えているかっていうと
びっくりするんです それであのお釈迦様がこのお坊さんに何したかというと
これはどう見ても栄養たっぷりな食べ物だから
御前供にしなくちゃあかんやと思って
朝いただいて もう食べる
お釈迦様はもらってくださいって一旦戒律設定だから
一般人もそれ知りますからね
新しいものってメンディサランドじゃあげましょうということになっちゃいますからね
それであの 御前供だから食べちゃったんです
食べてからまた托鉢に行くでしょ
そしたら最悪 あの上であれ食べちゃうと
またやっちゃいますね
また同じ病気治らなかったんです
それでお釈迦様があのね
これではダメみたいですねと
それであの あの 5つのものは
まあ昼も夜も好きな時食べてくださいと
で 時間を消してあげるんですね
そうするとお坊さんたちが昼ご飯食べて
朝ご飯食べて昼ご飯食べても
もう吐いてしまっちゃうし
まあいいや それからまあバターとかハチミツとかね
黒砂糖とかお腹に入れておく
それでもう元気で で もうすごく修行を完成したんですよ
そういう風に一つ一つ
一つ お坊様がいろんな体の健康のことを教えられて
このマハーヴァッダパーリのベーサッチャカンダカというチャプターがありまして
そちらに全部記録してあります
そういうわけで 体と心の調整っていうのは厳密に必要
それであの 今の なんていうのは連携プレーっていうのもそういうことなんです
体がちょっと変わって座ってると
ちょっと左に曲がって座ってみたら心が変わりますよ
じゃあ右にまた別に変わっちゃうんです
だからまっすぐに座るんです
そこまで気をつけるんです
ちょっと私は厳しく言うでしょ
首を落とすなよと ちょっと首を落としただけでも
思考の流れがむちゃむちゃ変わるんです
恐ろしく変わっちゃうんです
ですから このすごくもう体も気をつけなくちゃいけないんです
だからといって体主義ではダメなんですね
体は道具だよと これも忘れてはいかん
体は道具だと覚えておけばぴったし公平なんです
はい それで話は終了です
時間はちょっと経過しましたけど
ありがとうございます
[applause]